ha jól értettem akkor a ezekből
bajnokságokat is szerveznek és és a
bajnokságok tehát amikor a versenyre
kerül a sor akkor csak mobil telefonal
lehet belépni hát általában igen
telefonos versenyeket szerveznek mivel
ez egy telefonos játék de van külön
ipadeseknek ühüm illetve pcseknek tehát
akkor külön ipaden is azoknak külön
kategóriában játszák csak a igen csak az
nem annyira nem annyira intenzíven
szervezik az olyanokat ühüm mi miért
gondolod hogy a mobil az az népszerűbb
ipaden nem élvezetesebb játszani nagyobb
k élvezetesebb csak könnyebb azon csak
könnyebb érted de van pcn is ha jól
értettem persze persze és
xboxon ht xboxról nem hallottam pcn
könnyebb játszani hát előnyösebb de
nehezebb hozzászokni